hello everyone and welcome to a game
that magnus carlsen once described as a
game for the ages the game is from the
2013 Tata Steel chess tournament and for
those of you who are older subscribers
on this channel you might notice that I
already made a video on this game I made
it some two and a half years ago but
well I will put a link to it in the
description below if you want to check
out the old version of the video once
this you know at that time this channel
was still in only 30 frames per second
and it's well the the videos were a bit
different then and I received the well I
actually received hundreds of requests
to redo this video in in my newer format
of making videos so hopefully you will
enjoy this one as this game really
deserves a more thorough analysis and
also do check out the world not do check
out do vote on our next big saga the
first link in the description below will
take you to the poll where you will be
able to vote I've checked out all of
your hashtag saga suggestions and I've
well those those suggestions that
occurred more often I put them in the
poll so do vote on it though the winner
in the poll will not be automatically
the winner of the next saga but it will
greatly influence my decision so that
being said let's check out the game
eleven with the white pieces opens with
d4 we have d5 by Anand c4 and c6 sorry
about that
with Knight to f3 continuing development
tonight to f6 Knight to c3 and we have E
six the semi Slav is on the board we
have III by 11 preparing to develop the
light square Bishop and the Knight B to
d7
I will rush up to d3 and only now that
the Bishop was developed you make the
bishop lose the tempo so d captaincy for
Bishop captures and b5 further expanding
on the Queen side pushing the bishop
back and now the most common move here
today is a six but Anand goes for Bishop
to d6 it is one of them one of the lines
that he prepared and he prepared it very
well with castles by 11 castles by Anand
and now Queen to c2 putting more
pressure on the h7 phone Bishop the b7
by Anand preparing rook c8 at some
when c5 will be played so one of the
reasons why I'm more popular move for
example is a six there so winning play
c5 the b5 phone is already protected but
okay with a three by 11 and now rook the
c8 as planned and now nice the g5 and
here the h7 point is attacked three
times so what do you do here well there
are a couple of ideas if you just play
something like h6 the night goes back
assumes a more central square and the
game continues basically nothing really
goes on here on the other hand after
Knight to g5 Anand also has some very
sneaky options like Knight like Bishop
characters on h2 with check if King
captures you can just go an IG for check
and pick up this knife King the g1 Queen
captures here but this is not not the
best course of action for now for black
and here you don't have time to capture
on h7 because well you will also
actually Capra will also have to waste a
move to go back with the bishop because
well black will just play g6 and trap
your piece and you also have some bigger
issues to worry about so here you have
to kick the night away with f3 Knight
goes back and then the game continues so
it's not bad for black it's just it's
just that you know II for seems like a
very nice move opening up the bishop the
Queen might be a bit uncomfortable there
it's okay after Knight to g5 on
indefinitely has a you know a safety
safety move he has well if he wants to
be adventurous he also has that but he
decides to go for c5 and it's a it's a
line that later he said that he
experimented at home with and it's it's
just full of possibilities and the full
of possibilities is only an
understatement here for this game so
here we have Knight captures on h7
whittle by Levin also Bishop captures on
h7 is possible this is actually the the
engines favorite move and Anand said he
didn't mind he was expecting both moves
so it's not a problem and two years
after this game was played in 2015
Wesley so in Saint Louis had this
position against Samuel 7 and Wesley
captured on h7 but very quickly he was
he was lost so it's really a complicated
position but ok that's a completely
different game Knight captures
on h7 grabbing upon and here again what
do you do here well let's see what
happens if you just captured the night
if Knight captures knight then Bishop
captures night with check King to 88 and
now we're back to e4 you grab the clean
pawn I see Bishop captures Queen
captures and the game continues yeah you
don't even have a queen and c2 so black
can claim very little compensation here
for the for the lost pawn so white would
just be a pawn here in in a better
position on the other hand after Knight
captures on h7 you could go for c4 c4 is
also very sneaky claiming that okay you
you have a pawn but your Bishop will be
will not be very active at the end of
the line now night chapters in f6 with
Czech Knight captures Bishop to e2 end
ok here it's a little bit better you're
still down upon but at least you've
you've reduced the quality of the bishop
here but still even though even though
the engine might give this well
depending on the age and depending on
how much time you give it to who could
give white or even black the advantage
point is if you look at this position
it's white who has all of his pieces you
know behind his pawns and it's black who
has here the the bishop pair from hell
you know the knight can move the Queen
can jump into the attack so I'm pretty
sure everyone would rather play black
here okay after Knight captures on h7 on
and it doesn't go for Knight captures or
for c4 but rather Knight to g4 just
opening up attacks everywhere now dh2
point is under attack ideas like Queen
to h4 fall by queen characters here with
mate or possible and now how do you
defend this well obviously first we have
to ask ourselves is it possible to
capture the roof if it's possible to
capture the rook we should just capture
the roof but it's not just Bishop
captures an h2 King h1 and Queen
captures on H n Queen h4 and white is
getting checkmated there's no no way
around this I just you know you move the
bishop and it's mate okay you can
prolong the game but that's that's
pointless another thing you could do xi
has h3 also a possibility but still you
get Bishop to h2 check King to h1 and
now Queen to h4 a very devious move
threatening Queen captures on h3 because
the the G pawn is pinned you will not be
able to recapture
so it's a it's a very crazy position
where white seemingly has to go either
better up to e4 or even d5 and it's well
it's just a whole mess of the position
but it would be pointless to analyze it
since this is now a completely different
game and it would anything can happen
here and 11 decided that this is a mate
perhaps too much to calculate over the
board as its Anand who definitely
surprised him
so after night the g4 he didn't go for
the lines we mentioned he went for f4
just prevented straight out this Bishop
captures an h2 move and okay now here on
and again what what to play here he
plays C captures on d4 and with seek
after Sundy for Allen starts well
basically he starts creating a
masterpiece here we have C capture son d
4e capture son before and now for those
of you who maybe have never seen this
game feel free to pause the video and
try to find well the best idea for black
in this position while I give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations on
helping Anand create his immortal game
and for those you who just want to enjoy
the show if you found Queen to h4 it is
possible to play this but white-white
can defend here it's not a problem he
will push h3 and after you try
night-night here just you know if Knight
captures then you get the other night
into the attack you will just get Knight
captures and f6 with check so you'll
have to cap Trebek and now Queen to f2
offers a queen trade defends everything
and white white survives this attack so
after each capture Sundy for Anand
played Bishop to c5 and this is just
where where all of the craziness happens
and it's not that Bishop to c5 is a hard
move to find what follows is hard to
find and this is what aren't finds here
what do you do
well obviously can you capture the
bishop okay let's check it out if D
captures on c5 Knight captures on c5 and
not what happens here okay the bishop is
under attack here so you could either
move the bishop or or or capture the
rook let's let's let's see what happens
if you capture the rook and which is I
mean it's if it's possible you should do
it but there aren't all that many all
that many great moves because after
Knight captures both of the Knights now
control the
f2 square and now there's a very little
you can do against Queen to d4 check so
here you could try h3 to create a
breeding room for a king it's the only
useful move
but again just Queen to d4 check King to
h1 and not Knight to f2 with check what
do you do here you don't really have a
lot of options if you go to g1 then you
you face a lot of nasty discoveries so
you you're gonna have to capture the
knight rook captures Knight captures and
I have to with check King to h2 and then
now just King captures an f8 and here if
you look at it the material on the board
is equal but White's position is just
disgusting it's the knight cannot move
as the Queen will be hanging and c2 you
still have to develop your pieces and
black is white is just well in black is
in a much better position even though
the engines might might not give black
all that much advantage but it's just
hard to play this with white with black
being so developed and it's also not
that difficult to calculate so instead
of D captures and c5 11 tries a
different move just Bishop to e2 he
wants to eliminate this guy from g4 and
now comes the move that like I said
Bishop to c5 is not not the craziest
thing you could find but finding two
moves that come in a row like this it's
just awesome so here Anand uses the tall
principle and tall said you know even if
the two of your pieces are under attack
offer a third one because when it's
finally your opponent's move he can only
capture one of them so here on unplaced
Knight to e5 and here just everything is
hanging and what do you capture here
again okay we already discussed the pawn
characters on c5 it doesn't really work
but now that the knight is an e5 it's
even worse okay you cannot capture the
night with the D pawn because the D pawn
is pinned there would be checked but you
could play pawn captures night here do
you see what an ins idea was if if just
pawn captures night it's actually a
forced mate in four so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
very nice idea so for those who were
able to do it I'm sure you're no
stranger to this modern mate and for
you just want to enjoy the show its
Queen captures on d4 with check now you
could you could postpone mate with
Bishop d3 but we're not even gonna
discuss that King h1 and now just Queen
to g1 check you sacrifice the Queen for
a nice modern night the f2 mate which
became possible after the bishop came to
e2 since the Queen no longer and guards
the f2 square but okay obviously you
cannot capture the night what what other
solutions are there can you just play h3
can you just you know say I don't want
any pieces can you just go away you know
from the Kings side not really because
here just Bishop captures on d4 again
with check King to h1 and now Queen to
h4 again with the terrible threat of
just Queen captures on h3 because the
Jeep on as soon as the King comes to h1
is pinned this is the biggest problem
White has here so here
Knight g5 not allowing Queen captures on
h3 and now f5 claiming that white white
doesn't have a good move here and white
has to play something F captures on e5
now comes the Knights the f2 check
finally King to h2 and now Bishop
captures on e5 with check King to g1 and
now finally Queen to g3 threatening
Queen captures and G to mate and you
don't really have a good move if you if
you capture tonight with the rook to
guard the G to pawn queen h2 check King
to f1 and now Queen to h1 is mate and
even if you don't even if you try and
defend the position with Bishop to f3 to
block the the Bishop from b7 you still
get Knight e4 and it's just it is just
disgusting the night covers the f2 EDF
to square a queen to h2 will be made so
here you cannot capture it because the
Queen hangs if you capture with the
Bishop dangerous Bishop captures not
nothing good happens there and if you
may if you try to make room for the king
with rook the one then queen h2 check
King to f1 and now you just capture
Bishop captures and c3 let's say capture
so rope captures and the Queen doesn't
have a good square you can't go here you
can't go here if you go if you go to e2
you block the Kings escape route
so just Queen to h1 will be made you
could try Queen to be 2 but then just
rook captures on f3 it's just a
beautiful night capture screen h1 check
you can block
tonight's the g1 and now nights the g3
with Czech king to e1 and now just Queen
captures on g1 and you will very quickly
once the double rock enters the game
yeah the King started the King hunt
we'll start going to have to check you
can block this with King to see three
let's say Queen to see five check force
the King back King today to now you get
the rook into the game rook to d8 check
King to e1 and now let's say Queen to g1
is mate if weiter doesn't want to part
with the Queen so after this night dt5
what a white really doesn't have all
that many options you could try a since
the night is no longer on d7 guarding at
this world you could try just capturing
the bishop but it's still just Queen to
d4 check and there's there's still
nothing to do about it you don't even
need the Bishop on c5 anymore
because after the King moves just
Knights to f2 check and now if King g1
then of course I will show it since
maybe some of you are new you don't know
smothered mate I'll double check from
the from the Queen and the night and
after the King moves you against
sacrifice and g1 rook captures and the
knight to F 2 is again mate so a lot of
modern mates in the position
so after this knife do you have to check
you will have to capture it with rook
captures here but now just Queen
captures and now you really don't have a
lot of good ways to prevent mate now you
could try something but there isn't all
that all that much you can try you can't
go bush by three if that well just just
Queen to f1 is mate also the Queen would
be hanging well key of where everyone
prefers mate but there are just no good
moves here for whites to defend so here
after tonight the bg5 and it really
takes a lot to calculate this move 11
just said ok or off with one of the
attackers Bishop captures and g4 but and
of course it doesn't care about that he
plays a bunch of characters and d4 with
check King to h1 and now Knight captures
and g4 again opening up all of the
possibilities
you cannot play g3 if you play h3 you
run into again into a lot of trouble
after Queen to h4 so here on earth sorry
11 has to play something and
Knight captures on f8 and it it is in
fact the strongest move you just grab a
piece and well hopefully you can get
quinta h7 check if you can get Quinn to
h7 check you you're definitely defending
and even if you capture the night Queen
to h7 could post some problems for Anand
so after night captors and I fade island
please f5 he says no this game is
definitely not about material so let's
just continue the attack so what can
what can you play here if Knight
captures any six seems nice the queen is
under attack the bishop is under attack
but Queen h4 and you're never defending
mate
there's no defense against this maid h3
again runs into mate because the the G
point is again pinned so after f5 Knight
to g6 this is the the only possible move
as it guards the h4 square prevents the
Queen from reaching the age Foursquare
but now Queen to f6 and now Annan's plan
is simple the bishop pair from hell is
is you know fully operational and the
Queen just needs to get to the H file
and that's it
we have h3 hoping that the knight
retreats or something but there there is
no that there is no escape just Queen
captures and g6 if you capture the
knight of course Queen anywhere along
the H file is made since the dark square
Bishop covers the g1 square so after
Queen captures and g6 we have Queen to
d2 but it doesn't help with Queen to h5
and now you could try some ideas here
because again just Queen captures on h3
is deadly
you cannot allow this and now 11 played
Queen to d3 but the even the strongest
line rook to f3 just allows black to
trade down into a superior game for
example might have to check King h2 and
now you capture material back Bishop
captures an f3 Queen captures Queen
captures Queen captures Queen G captures
an f3 and now Knight to d3 and you get
the same game where ok material is equal
but White has no moves you cannot
develop the bishop because well you lose
the the B to pawn you cannot capture the
pawn here that's very important not to
this line if you capture the pondan just
you just play rook the sea to check and
after the King moves and now you bring
the bishop back to b6 and here you're
losing a piece there's no square for the
bishop
you cannot go here the recovers that's
where the bishop covers this square so
there's there's no no good move here
whatever you play just row captures here
and it's game over so you will not be
able to capture the pawn and if you
don't do it if you just continue the
game King g3 it's just very simple a six
additional defense to the b5 pawn and
after white play something like Bishop
to D to you there's no other move you
can play there's just no move you will
have to play something like this and
then you start losing pawns and then
it's just a much better pawn structure
for black will be a completely winning
endgame so of course level knows this
and it's not all that hard to calculate
so he plays Queen to d3 guards the h3
pawn this way and he tries to hold
everything together but feel free to
pause the video for the last time here
and find the winning move for black
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a
beautiful finisher to the game now Queen
to h4 does win the game and it is
possible to play this but it would not
be such a such a beautiful immortal game
if Anand played this instead of the move
he played for those of you who found
Bishop to e3 congratulations you have
just created any mortal game and of
course for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show because here white is
without a move now the bishop blocks the
Queen's defense of the h3 pawn Queen
captures on h3 there's no defense about
this if you capture still pointless and
just Queen captures on h3 in g1 Queen
captures and g2 is made if you don't do
it of course if Queen captures then just
Knight captures you lost the Queen and
you are again getting mated and here
rook to a3 like in the previous lines
doesn't do anything because you just
capture it and well there's there's no
move here captures and Queen captures
will again be made because the bishop
covers the g1 square so after Bishop to
e3 11 are in and resigned unmoved 23 and
this beautiful game was created by by
Vishwanath on onon that I believe to
this day is considered to
his immortal game and now I do believe
that this time we did it better we we
explored more possibilities and the
shoulder water what a crazy game this is
and we did it in 60 frames per second so
III do hope that we really got the job
done you know at least until we get this
channel up or two I don't know maybe 120
frames per second
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and here are the final
standings of this tournament I don't
know if I mentioned this the previous
time but just in case
even though 11 an island played a
brilliant tournament and created this
beautiful immortal game it was actually
Magnus who won the tournament showing
that he's ready to take on the world
champion I don't know if I mentioned it
during this game on and the was the
world champion this is Tata Steel so
it's played in January and well Ireland
is still a world champion reigning
supreme but Magnus showed that he is
able to win the tournament to one and a
half point ahead of second place arena
and two whole points ahead of third
place which won a tournament and and
sharing Sergey Karjakin so he's
definitely on the move but yeah that's
that the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
really enjoyed making the video for the
second time is it's just just a
monstrosity of a game you know so many
possibilities that Bishop c5 followed by
Knight d5 your your friends at the bar
in the library are gonna go go nuts
so I do hope they enjoy it as well I
would like to thank beyond Goodman son
Domon and her cracka for her
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos serum
thank y'all for watching and I will see
you soon
checking up and your wonderful
suggestions and do do vote on the next
big saga the poll is the first link you
will see in the description below so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day